I I can't uh uh stop reading enough
content or studying this guy enough and
you know you look at RFK says something
very unique in the interview where he
says in the documentary where he said
there is no man where there is more
statues buildings streets named after
him than Kenneth JFK right now if the
Churchill may be there a couple other
names maybe there but you know Kennedy
being what he did but why why uh
why the level of interest in his story
what caused you to say I really want to
investigate the story even more
well history is crucial because if less
you know where you came from if you
don't know where you are I mean it
becomes
in a sense America is
not really agreed on its history and
that's one of the reasons I did this
untold history we don't we have a lot of
Mythology in our country there's a myth
about America there's a myth about
America and there are facts and in our
history we tried to bring out facts that
we don't deal with we don't even know so
that's why it's called Untold it's there
it's known but it's been hidden
and of course among the all these many
facts is the fact that you know among
others is World War II which is still
partly motivating our ideology in the
world that there's a Hitler out there
and that we're all and we're the
Defenders of freedom and democracy is a
large is is is also a myth in the sense
that we did not win World War II we had
the Russians were the ones who broke
their back and took the most casualties
and actually tore the guts out of the
German war machine and the Churchill
said so himself
they were the sacrifice
27 million people died many of them 810
million were military their their
casualties were so much higher than ours
and four-fifths of the German military
machine was destroyed on the Eastern
Front
one fifth in the west so by by the time
D-Day happened in 1944
and we landed and it was a great big
myth but that that was that was late in
the war by 43 the war was turning and
early 44. because it was after after
Stalingrad the Russians had turned and
it was starting to chase the Russians
they're starting to chase the Germans
out of Russia that's a huge important
point that is part of this history
that's distorted and then of course I I
go to the place where JFK has killed and
I trying to explain in these
documentaries why he was killed that's
the most important question what was the
reason what would be the benefit of it
what would change after he was killed
and if you look at the record aside from
civil rights Lyndon Johnson changed
pretty much everything that Kennedy was
doing he cut off the relationships with
with the Africa with the Middle East
with Indonesia with Vietnam he became
another kind of creature the
old-fashioned way of doing business from
Eisenhower and Dulles brothers that is
without doubt and we go into some length
to to make this point to their American
public they have to learn this you have
to watch the you've seen the four-hour
version so you know there's more history
there and the two-hour version is called
Revisited the four-hour version is
called Destiny betrayed uh they're both
available the four hours available on
on uh Shout Factory and it's also
available on you can rent it on I think
Amazon or no you have to buy it actually
it's a digital purchase because it just
came out yesterday it's going to be on
iTunes it'll be on Apple can I get it
yeah I'll get that apple in iTunes and
there's two of them that one and the
other one they did with the nation the
12 episodes I'll get I'll watch both of
them the 12 episodes is until history
that was 2012. but that has some great
stuff on World War II and and the Cold
War the Cold War as well as up to the
Iraq War go go to to what you said so
you said the real reason to do the
documentary to see why like the whole
the why right okay so for you like did
you catch yourself going on a rabbit
hole and and saying you know because I
interviewed the Mobsters gangsters Sammy
the bull Michael Francis Frank colada
then I went to to Clint Hill who was the
secret service agent to Jackie to see
what he had to say and you know and then
I went to Abraham Bolden who was the
first black African-American secret
service agent and then I went to Cyril
wecht who was one of the what do you
call them the person who what do you
call serious jobs yeah and then Jim and
all these things I'm doing so colors I
went down the rabbit hole to find kind
of figure out but for you what when
you're by yourself and the whole thing
is done and you watch it what are you
thinking who do you think was afraid of
revealing the truth about what happened
with uh Kennedy is it CIA
when you see the these huge changes
these are huge changes in foreign and
domestic policy except for civil rights
that's the only just as you know Kennedy
submitted the bill a Civil Rights Act
and it was it was beautiful on his
momentum beautiful speech and based on
the momentum of his death Johnson
finally got it passed that was the
beginning of and they make Johnson into
a hero but he's not a hero because those
people who say this was a smooth
transition are dead wrong it's rubbish
really rubbish Kennedy was killed for a
reason and you have to look at the
highest levels of our society who would
hate him or resist him he was disliked
we know for his civil rights stance in
the south South George Wallace said that
he would not win the south in the 64
election we know that he had
he said quite openly after the Bay of
Pigs and after the Missile Crisis he
avoided war twice with Cuba this is
serious he avoided two Wars the second
one that the Missile Crisis could have
been the war that ended mankind that was
a huge nuclear potentially conflict to
save this country from two Wars is as to
me is as important as what the Russians
did in World War II because if they
hadn't done what they had done we would
American casualties which were 450 000
might well have been two three million
more just to get through the Hitler The
Fortress that Hitler had built in in
Europe
it's a big deal my father could have
been killed your father's we wouldn't
even be here people don't unders they
they agree there's a there's a easy
presumption that we're alive and we we
can we have these choices but we
wouldn't even be alive to make those
choices so uh I'm very my gratitude is
enormous to to both the Soviet Union and
to
to John Kennedy who uh was killed
because he wouldn't go to war against
Cuba now the Vietnam thing they accused
me of that one too but it's been proven
correct Mr McNamara is the Secretary of
Defense McGeorge Bundy his National
Securities advisor have since written
books since my movie came out saying
that he was going to pull out of Vietnam
win or lose win or lose McNamara was
very clear about that in his book in
retrospect
uh and you have to understand these are
people they were Hawks at that time of
Vietnam so they're they're not
interested in saying they're admitting
that I was they were wrong they're
saying Kennedy really was clear about it
but that he couldn't announce it
publicly couldn't make a big deal of it
because he had to get elected he was
going to run against Barry Goldwater who
was a hawk right you have to be in
America you can't get elected unless
you're a tough guy so if you enjoyed
this little segment from the podcast
click over here to watch the entire
podcast and if you're not subscribed to
the Channel please do so take care
everybody
[Music]